here are this week's top movies remember  when the holidays were actually fun in  bad mom's Christmas holidays and  visiting mothers are combustible moms  don't enjoyed they give joy that's how  being a mom works this year Christmas  both families together two families  sharing the holidays are put to the test  in daddy's home - you got a pump fake  that thing all night you gonna take a  shot Brad good a world-famous detective  Hercule Poirot in Murder on the Orient  Express  a famed detective investigates a  trainload of suspicious passengers the  real killer is right here one of you  people see what's hot in theaters with  this week's fantasy patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]